[Musique]
pamela participer à danse avec les stars
se passer et je pense qu'on est obligé
danse avec pamela
franchement est-ce que ça il me le dira
pas mais là venez avec moi est ce que
vous pouvez faire
venez avec moi bien mathieu attention
madame venez là on va mettre une musique
est un peu difficile de danser dans le
sanwi alors venez la fédé là et là c'est
plus facile année là c'est là que je vis
ma tu as très envie de danser avec vous
et jean-michel dansera avec vous après
aussi oui à michel il a très envie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
il a fait ça danse on va voir les babas
mais là va dire qu'ils dansent le mieux
jean michel bergue
[Applaudissements]
l'équipe et avec l'autre cache les pieds
attention michel visy que ça va venir
[Applaudissements]
sa mêlée dégueulasse
pamela il est nul non non ce n'est pas
facile
je veux d'abord je veux d'abord basa
m'agace à new castle
[Applaudissements]
toujours
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
un gars
l'art est de plein air
[Applaudissements]
allez
elle tue la touche ma
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la gimone attention
pado
elle voulait parler du coup je pensais
qu'ils pensent que je suis bazadais qui
formate une musique orientale
est-ce que ça me rappelle sa sur la tête
de ma mère à chaque fois que chiot
j'étais en boîte à fait mma avant d'être
connu
à chaque fois qu'ils avaient une musique
orientale tous les gars tourné vers moi
ce pour toi c'est moi qui m'étais ya
rayah apple à ton père ou dj alors
attendez avant qu'on danse
j'aimerais juste qu'on soit un petit
kiff caroline et paris là ça c'est pour
le kiff on lit les femmes et la police
mais on peut se dépêcher a annoncé
savais pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci à toi mais là je sais que tu as
vécu un cauchemar allait peu merci
pamela kaki talent à qui elles ont lieu
dans ces mafieux chinois ainsi que tel
c'est pas c'est pas lui c'est el haouès
et
[Applaudissements]